mais là messieurs bonjour et bienvenue à
cette autre édition de tam-tam canada
une émission particulièrement chargée en
tout cas comme les autres on a
aujourd'hui le plaisir de recevoir un
auditeur de rci qui nous écoute depuis
très longtemps du liban alors donc il
avec nous en chair et en os en studio on
parlera aussi aujourd'hui d'une
municipalité de nord du nord de montréal
qui envisage de traîner en justice la
communauté juive hassidique ali chantal
tiéné va nous dire pourquoi on parlera
évidemment c'est l'été on parlera de
pollution sonore parce que l'été a
beaucoup de bruit alors quelles sont les
conséquences pour la santé de 500
dossiers que ismaël ou la sienne a suivi
pour nous et on va finir avec un peu de
littérature la bonne littérature de la
littérature amusante avec ma collègue
marie jo obama risque de nous parler
d'un livre très intéressant résidence
secoua qui s'intéresse aux personnes
âgées des différentes origines dans là
je vous en dis pas plus parce que maryse
vous en parlais tout à l'heure
mais pour commencer combien de gens
parmi vous avais déjà se sont déjà
plaints d'avoir entendu des choses
négatives susurre sur vous sur les
autres 2 si vous avez participé à cet
exercice là donc de médisance ou le
commérage à loos un sujet qui a
intéressé
notre première invitée qui a fait un
livre l'addition livre intitulé lire
dans l'âme d'une commerce et de jénine
gags et des jeunes gag un bon jour et
demi
bonjour alors et génie d'abord qu'est-ce
que vous amener à vous pencher sur cette
thématique là du commérage
mais en fait c'est de l'observation
or pour commencer j'ai observé beaucoup
de choses autour de moi c'est sûr qu'il
ya eu un élément déclencheur dans le
fond qu'a fait en sorte que ça m'a
poussé à aller un peu plus loin mais je
ne me met déjà la réflexion depuis
depuis déjà quelques années et c'était
tellement déclencheur là mais en réalité
comme je l'expliquais un peu au départ
dans le livre le fait d'être dans un
groupe de se sentir bien six de suite
puis par la ce
et de se rendre compte que à cause des
affaires entre guillemets qui n'ont pas
vraiment d'importance mais qui sont
passés par le biais de la médisance du
commérage l'esprit de groupe i le
positif qui avaient ou d'effacer des
friqués qui ont certes fait face à
quelque chose que l'on voulait pas
forcément au départ au début en fait de
lost ont commencé son vol à aix ce
n'était pas ma première observation j'en
ai fait plusieurs dans plusieurs milieux
ça m'a interpellé puis je me suis dit là
il faut en parler parce que dans
certains pensaient que je trouve que
c'est quand même tabou en fait d'en
parler
voilà et pour ceux qui ne savent pas au
fait est ce qu'on peut définir les
termes c'est quoi le commérage en
quelques mots ou une commère dans le
titre et nous dira le fait simplement de
parler dans le dos des autres de
rapporter des 1ers sur les autres dans
la plupart du pape ou pas forcément
auditifs sont souvent des rapports tâche
qui font du mal à autrui ce pas
forcément pour chanter les louanges des
personnes ou justement faire du mal
consciemment ou inconsciemment ça fait
mal à la personne à la personne
concernée est ce qu on a une espèce de
portraits de portrait robot de la comair
la commère en fait ça peut être tout le
monde vous et moi c'est sûr qu'on a tous
déjà d'une façon ou d'une autre
participé à ce type d'exercice
on a on l'a déjà fait c'est sûr que on
est intense pas de la même façon selon
les personnes il en accueille dans les
groupes
on sait que cette personne est quand
même plus un temps sur ce type de
comportement que d'autres personnes mais
de façon générale ça peut être monsieur
tout le monde puisse à ça on peut se
retrouver en train de le faire dans un
contexte différent
est ce que on a une propension aux
commérages selon le sexe ou selon l'âge
bon en réel
c'est difficile à dire parce que les
études là dessus on en serait en fait
l'idée viendrait à l'esprit serait les
femmes entre guillemets commérages mais
c'est pas toujours ça c'est pas toujours
ça c'est juste que dans le fond
dépendamment des steaks ça se fait
différemment et les composants
différents et puis la violence en fait
des fois de la façon dont ça se fait pas
toujours de la même façon chez les
hommes ou chez les femmes ou d'un âge un
autre plus on grandit ou plus haut en
matière
et puis un stage expulsé subtil et plus
ça fait mal aux états unis oui maryse
j'avais je voudrais vous demander est ce
que les réseaux sociaux sont en train de
changer la nature du commérage peut-être
pas la nature mais elles sont les
réseaux sociaux sont vraiment cons de
mettre en avant une partie face du
commérage qu'on ne voyait pas forcément
il ya beaucoup de choses dans le fond
que ont condamné puis on n'avait pas
conscience de l'ampleur du phénomène
avec les réseaux sociaux on se rend
compte qu une personne derrière son
clavier d'ordinateur peut être vraiment
très virulent dans sa façon de présenter
les autres des touches dans ça nous met
brusquement une réalité qu'on n'avait
pas forcément issus de cette façon-là
par le passé pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait
du commérage est ce qu'il ya un besoin
on va dire que c'est pas quelconque de
de fer se prêter à cet exercice malsain
oui dans le livre j'explique les causes
possibles du commérage y en a mille deux
cent cinquante on parle de quelques unes
de ses causes là de façon générale
dépendamment des contextes ça peut aller
au temps du désir en fait de se mettre
en avant à la à la jalousie ça peut être
de plusieurs ordres en fait il ya
plusieurs causes possibles départs maman
comme j'ai dit du contexte
dépendamment de l'âge des fois aussi
dans des contextes d'écoles secondaires
et tout pour être
pour être tenue à l'école on dit d
affaires sur les autres puis on est
comme un réservoir important ça fait en
sorte on est plus populaire est situé
donc il ya vraiment des causes multiples
à ce phénomène
ali shante al oui je ne sais pas
spécialement lu votre ouvrage
mais entendre les uns et les autres j'ai
comme l'impression qu'il ya disons c'est
un lien un parallèle entre
l'intimidation et le commérage parce
qu'on rapporte des propos négatifs sur
les autres ce qui peut contribuer à
briser le stim de soi quelque part
est-ce que vous avez constaté ce lien là
vous avez essayé d'établir cette
relation là oui oui je pas
spécifiquement d'intimidation dans le
contexte scolaire mais ça se trouve en
fait partout parce que même dans le
commérage de gros temps de s'expliquer
dans le livre est ce qui se passe
souvent c'est que il ya une leader entre
guillemets dans le sens du commérage qui
attendent le pouvoir dans le groupe puis
ce leader là les autres vont venir vers
le leader en question non pas par amour
ou par autre chose mais c'est souvent
parce que ses autres personnes ont peur
de devenir ses victimes
donc il une autre forme d'intimidation
en fait une des passions qui n'est pas
toujours celle confiance dans les écoles
ainsi de suite
bien que celle qu'on pense existe aussi
beaucoup par le biais du commérage mais
mairie au niveau des adultes dans le
milieu de travail institué des plus
anciens dans le milieu de travail qui
distille des rumeurs sur les plus les
nouveaux en fait parce que les anciens
d'ennuyeux dans le milieu de travail
bénéficient la plupart du temps d'une
immunité de par leur ancienne et dont
ils sont pénibles en fait t'as fait en
sorte que pour eux ça peut être plus
facile de passer par ces mécanismes d
intimidation là pour arriver à leurs
fins jenny vous dites que bon le caméra
et se nourrit du malheur des autres
est ce à dire que dans un environnement
très positif le commérage ne suivent ne
survivrait
beaucoup effectivement dans un
environnement où la culture du positif
le commérage aurait tendance à
disparaître
le réseau environnement où on valorise
le fait de rapporter qu'est ce qui s'est
passé quelque part le fait de rapporter
les malheurs des autres instituts ne
sont pas forcément des environnements
gay n'est pas des environnements
forcément où on se lève le matin puis on
a envie d'y aller
donc oui effectivement d'avoir un
environnement positif où les gens
pensent plus à comment faire pour
avancer même si on a des défauts même si
on travaille avec des personnes qui ont
des défauts comment leur faire des
critiques constructives qui vont les
amener à gravir et non pas les détruit
sans qu'elles soient au courant plus que
ça a un impact négatif sur sur leur vie
parlant justement d'impact alors quelles
sont les conséquences les conséquences
d'abord pour les victimes du commérage
qu'est ce que ça peut avoir comme il
fait dans mon ouvrage en fait je passe
en revue plusieurs types de conséquences
mais déjà soi même le fait de la prendre
comme souvent une rupture de confiance
avec entre la victime puis le bourreau
il ya ceux pour que la victime peut su
réagir c'est à dire que réagir en
faisant elle aussi du commérage les
réactions peuvent être violentes mais
pas forcément violent physiquement bien
que ça peut l'être physiquement aussi
on peut tomber en fait dans des
relations vraiment spécial dans le sens
que chacun essaie de se venger
puis utilisent cette arme là contre les
autres offres on peut aussi arriver dans
des contextes d comme où on à
l'intimidation il poussa palais très
loin on a souvent parlé du suicide au
niveau des plus jeunes
d
on a souvent aussi vu dans le milieu de
travail qu'elle voit qu'il ya beaucoup
de roulement de personnel des milieux
stressant où c'est difficile d'arriver
au travail de ma faim c on travaille
plus à survivre en fait on travaille
plus à pouvoir se laisser aller au
travail le matin vraiment a dit
productif en puissante alice ans
qu'alain oui à jenny je veux savoir
c'est quoi votre intention derrière l'
ouvrage est ce que c'est juste de la
stigmatisation que vous faites ou vous
voulez appeler à un réel changement de
comportement de la part de ceux qui se
livre à cet exercice la dent dans la
démarche ancêtres c'est beaucoup plus un
mécanisme qui nous permet de nous
remettre lui-même en question c'est à
dire nous je mets plus moi donc c'est
une démarche qui permet en fait de
comprend déjà que en tant qu'humain on a
tous des faiblesses puis d'enfants de
tâches et nos faiblesses ne revient pas
exposées celles des eaux
donc c'est vraiment plus dans le sens de
on s'améliore comme personne puis on
s'améliore comme société c'est très loin
de la somatisation non c'est vraiment
dans le sens de l'amélioration personnel
puis de l'amélioration de la société
dans laquelle on vit
est ce que les sociologues ont passé les
diplômes en psychologie est elle aussi
intervenant clinicienne justement est ce
que l'on m'a parlé des conséquences au
niveau des victimes
mais au niveau des auteurs par exemple
est ce qu'il ya des conséquences pour
les personnes qui sont à l'origine où
les bourreaux on va dire la première
généralement on s'est fait hier que
j'appelle dans le vagin renforçateur
c'est à dire que souvent si ça continue
c'est parce qu'il ya quelque chose de
positif que la personne qui fait bâcher
là dedans mais le commérage vient aussi
avec une garantie de compliquer
parce que la plupart du temps c'est
parfait
de la personne justement c'est dans son
dos et que les personnes ça arrange
l'autre personne ne sache pas forcément
qu'elles sont à l'origine des problèmes
ou des rumeurs arrivent de la firme
scéno la personne finit par être au
courant c'est sûr c'est arrive avec une
garantie de cons qui arrive aussi avec
eux la possibilité de la réplique
il faut par la suite de supporter la
réplique qui va venir avec donc ça m'a
forcément dans des situations
inconfortables et improductive oui
j'allais vous demandez génie est dans un
cas comme celui là lorsqu'on s'aperçoit
qu'à quelqu'un qui nous parle dans le
dos est ce qu'on doit intervenir ne pas
intervenir ou leur apporter à quelqu'un
comment les conseils pour gérer cette
situation là déjà
dépendamment du complexe on peut pas
toujours intervenir dans tous les
contextes puis on n'est pas toujours à
chaque fois donc dépendamment des
comptes est qu'il faut réfléchir à la
façon de réagir
des fois le fait de ne pas réagir dans
le fond c'est la meilleure des choses à
faire dans certaines circonstances parce
que la personne des fois on le fera vous
cherchez une réaction de nous parce que
quand je parle de rendre sattler c'est à
dire que la personne à une réalité une
attention venant de venir à partir du
moment qu'on coupe dans le rang
formateur c'est un peu comme j'ai une
récompense dont je faisais l'action dès
que j'ai pu la récompense l'action va
cesser les couches le fait aussi que le
premier âge vient souvent avec des
conséquences sociales c'est à dire que
quand la rumeur se répand ça fait en
sorte que c'est ce n'est plus une
histoire de personne à personne ça
devient plus les conséquences sont plus
aggravée dans le sens que dans la
société il ya des affaires des actions
qu'on peut lui poser parce que le regard
des autres ainsi de suite
dans ce contexte là c'est souvent
important de donner son point de vue ou
alors de trouver un loyer de de montrer
une autre image
de nous parce qu'en réalité ce n'est
plus juste entre la personne en question
puis nous mais ça a pris d'autres
proportions donc en qualité
la réponse est c'est contextualiser pour
réagir selon les concepts pour réagir en
réfléchissant c'est consternant c'est
aussi de notre de notre réaction
en tout cas livre très intéressant très
passionnant qui se lit très très bien
les bourrées de le conseil lire dans
l'âme d'une commère un ouvrage donc de
st génis gags et jenny comment est ce
qu'on peut faire pour se procurer ce
livre pour les gens qui nous qui nous
regarde en ce moment en ce moment deux
pages est disponible en ligne en version
électronique puis en version papier sur
amazon est le titre du livre sur amazon
voilà génie merci beaucoup d'avoir eu le
temps de nous parler aujourd'hui
merci au revoir
alors donc c'est vraiment livre que j'ai
lu avec beaucoup de plaisir en une
soirée ça se lit très bien ici comme je
vous dis c'est très pratique c'est bien
écrit six un style accessible
en fait ce genre de livre en classe dans
la catégorie de croissance personnelle à
l'oreille chabar bonjour bonjour merci
d'être là
alors vous êtes un fidèle auditeur dr si
vous ne venez du liban vous nous écoutez
depuis très longtemps et j'ai tout de
suite envie de vous demander votre
histoire d'amour avec merci ça commence
et quand ça fait depuis à peu près de
1986 lorsque j'étais en france
à la côte d'azur à nice et vous savez
c'est dans la région où on est près de
la mer la halle écoute des autres
courtiers mieux favorable j'ai vérifié
mes études secondaires là-bas et j'étais
seule mes paroles ont été arrêtées au
liban et pour les passes ton donc
j'avais
essayez donc dû écouter des ondes des
ondes radios des ondes radio de très
loin c'était la première fois des
capteurs radio canada international donc
c'était une radio d'un pays très loin et
qui parle le français et c'était très et
matrix est très aimable pour moi
d'écouter une station qui parlent
français et j'ai commencé à écouter à
suivre les radio canada international et
j'avais fait des correspondances et j'ai
participé aux émissions est comme ça
j'ai continué à suivre
radio canada international et vous
écoutiez quelle émission vous vous
souvenez à l'époque j'ai souviens qu'il
y avait deux
courrier des auditeurs et les infos
locales des cires canada et l'actualité
actualité oui c'était à l'époque et vous
savez qu'il y avait pas d internet
il y avait pas d accès mobiles il n'y
avait pas d'explication et c'était un
essai fut difficile de capter des
examens exercice réussi remettre
l'éguille au bon endroit pour pouvoir
écouter le son qui ne qui est incertain
parfois ça grésille nous a fait partie
de la beauté des des ondes courtes
est ce qu'il y avait un moment
particulier de la journée où c'était
plus facile pour vous d'écouter et si
oui bien sûr parce que au cours de la
journée c'était très difficile d'écouter
les ondes courtes donc après à partir de
l'histoire
je sais pas c'est pourquoi on peut
écouter facilement les ondes courtes à
partir de
des couchers de soleil je veux dire je
sais pas donc là les stations radio
mondiale va être facile à capter une
situation physique c'est les ondes
voyagement fait c'est la fréquence
l'habitude d'y danser cadre des
rencontres c'est beaucoup plus courte et
voyagent loin
biya moins d'interférence pendant la
nuit c'est ça en kart beaucoup plus
pendant la nuit pendant la soirée que de
la journée ici c'est à côté des si
l'émission il fait à côté d'un lac par
exemple ça voyage beaucoup plus loin
pacs explication physique physique est
ce que des événements ou des choses
baisse des sujets que vous aviez suivi
en exclusivité aux biens qui vous ont
marqué pendant ces six vous nombreuses
années d'aidés coûte deux derniers à
travers
[Musique]
et
à travers les lettons où j'avais écouté
les radio canada international ça mais
c'est qu'il m'avait plu de plus c'était
cool y ait moins de monde y est
présentée par la suite en paraphant part
en vacances en ce moment oui on vous
présente mes salutations salutations à
ses fins par an est-ce que vous aimiez
démission de stéphane c'était une
émission qui a beaucoup de diversité
c'est à dire il
il y avait des interviews avec des
le tuteur du monde et il y avait des 6 g
qui explique don changer mission il ya
il explique ainsi j'ai bien particulier
et répond aux questions des auditeurs
et il y avait des quiz à poser il
n'était qu'à doit toujours des souvenirs
des canadairs même des émissions plus
c'était alors la bon vous savez ici
n'est plus sur les ondes courtes quand
ce que vous avez quand vous avez appris
que essayé avant de les ondes courtes
pour migrer vers le web
comment est ce que vous avez réagi je
pensais au revoir parce que c'était un
pour moi c'est un bon souvenir avec les
radios coup des 11 euros d'autres
c'était à une
une information une malle la formation
qui gérait que j'ai entendu mais en
réalité c'était bien sûr s'était mis au
repos pour les souvenirs
je continue avec lui maintenant avec le
web
on espère
toujours les progrès des
et les soutiens de radio-canada ça mieux
sur le web vous excuse a besoin de calme
et c'est une différence au niveau du
confort de l'écouté ainsi de suite est
ce que vous préférez la version web où
vous êtes un peu plus nostalgiques de
des années 90 je pense qu'il est très
important pour les d'avoir le web mais
en plus si c'est s'il ya des
possibilités de voir des émissions
d'ondés
par exemple dans des capitaux dans des
capitales francophones par exemple paris
ni à beyrouth
c'est une ville francophone dont des
régions d'ondés en faisant des pendants
très longtemps effectivement si
effectivement la meilleure
le confort d'écouté meilleurs ont
diffusé localement fmi ce n'est pas plus
plus agréable que le on n'a plus besoin
de chercher la petite aiguille
oui il ya bien des difficultés avec les
aiguilles est actuellement l'émission
télé ne vous n'êtes pas sûr de dates de
classe légale à bord au bon moment
pendant pour le début de l'émission
ça faisait partie un pet est en ce sens
qu'il s'agit d'une autre station
prononcer dimanche
chacune des époques à son charme
oui alors est ce que vous aviez à force
d'écouter essayé comme ça au liban qu
est ce que vous aviez une image du
canada un portrait du canada qui se
dégageait à travers ce que vous écoutiez
comme ça à distance
ce qui m'a encouragé à visiter canada
c'était une l'imagination qui à travers
l'écouté de radio canada international
j'ai avant d'arriver à canada j'ai
l'impression qu'ils aient canada c'est
un pays où on sait qui c'est qui nous
rappelle au froid et à la neige à être
emprisonnés c'était l'idée pour moi
parce que toujours j'écoute des tons par
deux les émissions que l'attrait des
mois mais vous êtes arrivé et on est en
vagues de chaleur on a fait beaucoup de
choses mais en faisant les contacts avec
le canadien donc c'était pour séjourner
ici c'est très sale et c'est très
agréable
donc on peut supporter la température de
la plus basse basque et moi j'avais une
idée qui
c'est insupportable mais ça va ça va
très bien il y avait avec la température
la plus basse et le pays équipés pour
faire face à ces gens de quand datent de
température aussi alors bon là vous avez
visité depuis que vous êtes là vous avez
vous avez été tenues
j'ai commencé avec windsor c'est mon
harki qui habite là-bas qui avait son
travail et les canadiens est d'origine
qui venait j'ai étais c'est une ville un
peu qu'ils allaient la météo un peu
comparable au liban parce que ya pas
beaucoup d des basses températures
c'est une ville très calme puis j'ai
continué à ottawa
c'est la capitale du canada cga très
intéressant de visiter la capitale
donc c'est très calme et c'est une
capitale ccc la capitale du canada mais
c'est moins populaires comme que les
autres capitales du monde tessa juste ce
qui m'avait beaucoup plu
et maintenant je suis amené à la ville
les actifs valent d où se trouve la
maison de la radio
je suis content des visiteurs du canada
international et des rencontres et
l'équipe des radio canada international
vous personnellement dit kai et alice
sont les nouveaux la leonardo et toute
l'équipe des bons aimé que c'est qu'ils
n'ont même en cas c'était fin par an il
reviendra bientôt être très vite au
courant de votre passage et surtout
l'espace qui va aussi beaucoup
regrettaient de ne vous a pas vu en
personne parce que compte tenu de la
relation que vous avez est ce qu'après
si vous avez d'autres projets enfin pro
montréal c'est quoi la suite des choses
je vais et qui très malheureusement gp2
je vais le dire parce que je suis très
content ici spécialement à montréal
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d activités dont
dick cette ville c'est une ville très
active très vivante
je vais quitter à niort pour quatre
jours comme ça je termine je terminerai
mon trip pour détourner mon pays voilà
en tout cas ça nous a fait plaisir de
vous soyez là et que vous venez en
studio si c'est pour nous c'est toujours
plus intéressant d'avoir quelqu'un comme
vous qui symbolise un peu les gens qui
on parle depuis des années donc raif
chabal merci infiniment merci des mots
recueillir ici à la maison de la radio
je vous souhaite une très bonne journée
voilà merci merci ismaël oui aloïs mais
je me tourne vers vous parce que vous
allez aborder cette semaine un sujet
très intéressant c'est l'été et
quelqu'un qui dit été dit parfois
nuisances sonores souvent dit souvent
c'est ça il était souvent synonyme de ça
parce que les gens vont se défoulent
l'hiver on est resté comme disait tout à
l'heure monsieur monsieur chabal reste
un peu traître à la maison et là on en
profite on s'est ensuite on se déploie
en profitent du beau temps mais d'abord
qu'est ce qui est source de bruit
souvent les pays évidemment l'été on est
dehors puis c'est une saison courte donc
les gens en profitent pour faire
beaucoup d'activité et c'est la saison
où il ya les festivals donc au des
événements musicaux et autres donc le
bruit peut être omniprésent et surtout
il s'ajoute déjà au bruit ambiant que
l'on peut connaître pendant l'année
comme la circulation ou le bruit des
machines ou bruits de l'extérieur tout
simplement
et alors donc se brûle assez bon dans ce
un signe de vie sain de vie mais c'est
un signe de nuisance on parle maintenant
de pollution sonore donc exactement
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça la
pollution sonore c'est quand lorsque le
bruit nous empêche de vivre finalement
d'avoir notre quotidien et ce bruit
locke qui est insidieux parce que le
bruit n'a pas de conséquence directe à
la minute où à l'heure le bruit peut
avoir des conséquences sur plusieurs
années ton qu'on s'en rend compte
lentement des fronts ne s'en rend pas
compte jusqu'à qu'on avait des symptômes
justement qui sont liées à la nuisance
du bruit donc c'est quelque chose de
quand même d'assez complexes et parfois
au sida c'est dangereux et vous avez
justement rencontrer un spécialiste tout
ni lourd ou wiki qui en parle qui parle
des conséquences
alors quelles sont ses conséquences la
alors les conséquences que le professeur
anthony le roux a partagé son comme je
disais des conséquences à long terme
donc comme le bruit comme le professeur
expliqué le bruit sept ans qu'on réagi
instinctivement au bruit c'est à dire
que notre coeur va battre plus fort on
va soit l'éviter c'est à dire on
on va essayer de trouver des moyens de
ne plus l'entendre on va soit le
confronter donc il ya toujours à des
phénomènes ou des conséquences
biologiques sur notre corps et ses
conséquences la comme je le disais sont
liés soit au battement du coeur qui
s'accélère ou soit au stress et l
angoisse donc à la perte de sommeil la
fatigue et toutes ces symptômes là vont
générer des maladies et ces maladies
peuvent être diverses comme les arrêts
cardiaques
à force évidemment que le coeur se met à
battre on fragilise notre système
cardiovasculaire donc arrêt cardiaque le
seul à perte de sommeil aussi peut avoir
des conséquences très graves sur la
santé comme des maladies après nerveuse
de subvenir
est-ce que les gens identifient
facilement cette source de problèmes
faire dire tous les malaises que vous
évoquez ce que les gens font facilement
le lien avec le bruit ou bien parfois on
subit ça sans se rendre compte qu'au
fond tels problèmes qu'on a le stress
l'insomnie ce seuil et les gens savent
quand le bruit a des conséquences sur
leur vie quotidienne mais le problème
c'est qu'il n'ya pas vraiment de
possibilité de contrer le bruit
voilà c'est ça qui est difficile c'est
comment empêcher le bruit de rentrer
dans nos oreilles si ça c'est quelque
chose d biologiquement impossible on
ferme les portes on ferme les fenêtres
d'accord mais on est quand même dans une
situation de stress on essaye
d'amenuiser le bruit sans jamais
vraiment totalement l'empêché donc cette
même même les procédés qui nous permet
d'atténuer le bruit créé de l'angoissent
la colère du stress et donc des maladies
qui suit si j'ai très intéressant en
tout cas je vous encourage à aller sur
notre site pour en savoir davantage sur
ce sujet de ismaël est aussi surtout
écouter la conversation qu'il a eue avec
le professeur denis lourds ou mail merci
beaucoup merci merci beaucoup
alice bonjour bonjour didier alice alors
ça c'est quand même un sujet on dirait
pas passionnant un sujet délicat surtout
délicat qui oppose une municipalité dans
le nord 2
le nord de montréal dans les laurentides
en fait à la communauté hassidique
certes il convient alors de quoi
s'agit-il c'est quoi le problème
en fait on a affaire à une communauté
qui a une façon particulière de vivre
excusez moi pour eux la façon
particulière c'est leur rituel leur
éthique religieuse parce que c'est des
gens qui appartiennent à une communauté
religieuse c'est la communauté de
yeshiva et dont ils ont une manière de
vivre leur foi de façon très fervente
ils vont organiser de grandes soirées
festives où ils mangent ils boivent ils
jettent des déchets un peu partout et
quelque part on parler d'eux de
pollution tantôt donc il s'ensuit quoi
la pollution environnementale
et puis la pollution par le bruit la
population qui se plaint de trop de d'un
excès de bruit d'un excès de mouches
dans le quartier des gens qui vont
allumer d'un grand feu à la suite pour
brûler leurs déchets donc c'est une
situation franchement invivable pour la
population sont des gens qui sont allés
se plaindre à la mairie
l'amérique a essayé de s'entendre avec
la communauté avec les principaux
leaders de leur dire écoutez vous
contrevenez à une réglementation
municipale
on est quand même dans un quartier
résidentiel où les citoyens ont besoin
de calme de tranquillité pour pouvoir se
reposer tranquillement
écoutez on va essayer de trouver un
terrain d'entente et ils avaient
déménagé à paris
si la municipalité menace de les traîner
en justice parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'impact n'a pas jugé bon disons jusqu'à
présent n'y a pas eu d'entente une sim
possibilité a donné aujourd'hui à ce
qu'il faut en discuter davantage avec la
mairesse la mairesse avec qui je me suis
entretenu hier dans ces madame cathy
poulain cathy poulain qui dit oui en
même temps il ya un problème qui se pose
mais évitons quand même la
stigmatisation à outrance c'est quand
même une communauté qui qui qui a ses
droits donc il faut respecter ces droits
là ils ont un droit de culte mais
quelque part il ya les règlements aussi
qu'il faut respecter
donc ils sont en conclave aujourd'hui on
ne sait pas ce que ça devrait donner
mais bon on espère qu'ils vont pouvoir
trouver
un terrain d'entente une communauté on
vous l'avait un peu dit qu'il tient
qu'un la question de vivre en autarcie
qui a 111 ou est en fait ce que j'ai dit
dans mon article ces gens qui vise qui
vivent en quasi je vais dire vase clos
donc ils ont leur façon particulière de
fonctionner ils vont avoir leur propre
école leur propre médecin leur propre
secouristes donc ils sont comme un peu
c'est du entre nous deux lotos centrisme
qui frise quelque part ce qu'on appelle
l'isolationnisme
donc ils sont un peu comme une nation
dans la nation ça c'est pas de la
stigmatisation que je le fais parce
qu'ils forment un groupe à part dans la
société un groupe avec ses propres
règles
bon voilà tous les enfants vont à
l'école l'école publique que tout le
monde connaît oui mais il y en a qui
choisissent de scolariser leurs enfants
chez eux dans un petit groupe en
communauté et puis ça peut paraître
parfois parfois bizarre mais c'est leur
choix à respecter aussi qu'elle se
plaint de la santé parce qu'ils vont
aller dans les hôpitaux dans les
structures les friands privilégier leurs
propres hôpitaux par exemple s'ils
savent que si je me rends à l'hôpital
juif je vais peut-être rencontrer un
spécialiste qui va mieux me comprendre
si le plan culturel sur le plan je sais
pas moi de mes choix religieux ils vont
peut-être davantage se diriger vers vers
ce centre là donc comme je le faisais si
des gens qui sont très très auto centrée
sur elle-même qui ont leur façon
particulière de fonctionner voilà merci
encore notre deux side accès y que vous
pouvez lire et relire sur notre site à
les sens des mots merci infiniment
barry les yeux bonjour bonjour bonjour
maryse résidence séquoia alors ça c'est
un roman de rachid à fadel qu'il
montréalaise d'origine marocaine
vous avez lu le roman et vous avez aussi
vous envoûtent entretenu avec madame
j'ai vu ça durant mes vacances
un livre sur des petits vieux c'est
comme ça qu'on les appelle au québec les
gens qui ont un certain âge et indices
qui rit et qu'ils doivent à leur
résidence
parce qu'il ne peut plus s'occuper d'eux
mêmes hélas ce qui est intéressant dans
le lit de rachida c'est que on voit en
couverture que toutes les fenêtres de
couleurs différentes pourquoi parce que
dans cette résidence tout le monde it su
d'ailleurs
et là tous ces gens là doivent apprendre
à vivre ensemble et c'est ça qui est
drôle lada est là au début les gens
restent dans leur chambre et finalement
il ya des petits fatigué ou des petites
fatigante qui aiment cogné à la porte et
qui les invite à venir partager il y as
parlé et c'est là qu'on apprend par
exemple
questerre a survécu dans des camps de
concentration allemands et rachida qui
elle est d'origine marocaine qui venu
s'installer à montréal en 2000 elle a eu
l'idée d'inclure ce personnage parce
qu'elle avait rencontré la maman et à
quel numéro sur son bras c'est ce qu'on
faisait ou juifs dans les camps de
concentration
donc une vraie survivante d'accord de
concertation tout appétit ya aussi enzo
un italien qui comble de malheur est
homosexuel hélas son père déteste ça
alors ce sont vraiment des personnages
très bien campés il ya aussi une
discussion entre une québécoise louise
et chiraz du nehalem qui vient d'iran
qui ne portaient pas le voile en iran
qui a commencé à le porter ici
mais quitter répudiée par son mari parce
qu'elle ne pouvait pas enfanter alors
vraiment moi je me disais jamais je vais
passer à travers ce livre et leur
pendant mes vacances et j'ai
complètement été envoûté c'est super
intéressant
et là vous allez me dire un livre sur
les petits vieux pour les plus jeunes
c'est pas intéressant
non parce que c'est peut-être ce qui
nous est plus tard sans doute sur l'ailé
ça préfigure de ce qu'on aura bientôt
non mais c'est déjà mais si on y
arrivera cet âge là mais c'est vraiment
intéressante donc résidence séquoia
rachid al fadil et il ya un deuxième
tome qui s'en vient parce qu'elle n'ait
pas pu développer tous les personnages
qu'elle voulait dans un premier temps
dans ce premier tome est ce que on ouvre
on nous raconte d'abord les personnages
bien il ya au delà du fait que chacun
son histoire il ya des interactions au
nom l'interaction d'ailleurs un moment
non feinte de fait est là il y avait une
petite dame qui avait l'oeil sont
immenses yeux
finalement il valait 2 cadencée mais ce
sera très court
alors c'est ça qui nous tient en haleine
dans ce livre et c'est pour ça que je
vous le recommande
c'est publié aux éditions fides comme
quoi dans ces maisons là il ya des
histoires d'amour qui peuvent naître
mais la lutte et de l'amour ça ne
s'arrête pas je sais pas c'est vrai
qu'on parle pas souvent des résidences
et dans la vie dans les résidences parce
que la vie elle se finit pas en
résidence et une autre vie une autre
génération si vous savez ce qui est
intéressant
rachida m'fadel est allé lorsqu'elle a
lancé son livre dans une résidence parce
qu'ils coûtent signé la question allez
vous poser justement est elle plus tard
veut aller en résidence lorsqu'elle ne
pourra plus s'occuper d'elle-même et de
toute façon on se fait servir à manger
non pas les voir terreur des relations
avec les gens alors c'est parce que je
vous le recommande fortement
s'il perd intéresse donc on va suivre
cette recommandation de maryse bon alors
je pense qu'on a fait le tour
léo sur le front le front des
technologies je pense que c'est un peu
plus plus plus tranquille où il mais je
l'explication pour l'histoire des
liaisons de course
oui j'ai lu qu'il se propage les
normalement il se propage
les encours tendu d'élection c'est une
direction dit son
pour les autres dit il va frapper une
partie de la llose faire by par ces
rendre encore une fois en terre pis les
rayons de soleil il laisse pas que les
eaux montent à la ionosphère puis qui
force qu'ils fassent les rebondissements
à la soirée voire la nuit
particulièrement les ondes
il va y voyagent beaucoup plus loin
alors s'il paraît que ça me rassure que
l'international y est très bien entendu
achever au mexique et en argentine bien
au sud sur pas si bien que ça en soirée
ça va être excellent a chanté aussi
parce qu'ils voyagent beaucoup beaucoup
plus loin en tout cas merci pour cette
explication et sur ceux des amis je vous
remercie
mary's en fait chantal plaisir merci
merci de notre invité est notre invité
d'honneur raïs merci beaucoup d'être
venu merci merci beaucoup et les eaux
lors si l'homme orchestre qui participe
en même temps c'est grâce à lui que
grâce à lui et pierre mouneu que vous ne
voyez pas ici que de l'autre côté c'est
grâce à eux que nous voir les hommes
orchestres en 5 la voilà et merci aussi
au sénégal
marielle qu'on ne voit pas qui la femme
de l'ombre de l'autre côté mais qui est
très très efficaces et qu'on connaissait
la rc2 puis deux puis voilà merci
beaucoup et on s'est dit à bientôt aux
oies au revoir
je vous remercie
notre invité est notre invité d'honneur
merci beaucoup d'être venus et les eaux
c'est grâce à lui que côté